Війна, чи як назвали її у Кремлі, "спецоперація" мала завершитися за лічені дні.
Російські танки вторглися в Україну відразу з кількох напрямків.
З Білорусі на півночі, з підконтрольних проросійським сепаратистам так званих "ДНР/ЛНР", з самої Росії та з окупованого Криму на півдні.
План полягав у захопленні Києва з усуненням уряду та завоюванні якомога більшої території у якомога короткі строки.
Однак замість переможного бліцкригу Росія отримала затяжну війну.
Я передбачав, що українці шалено битимуться, і вони, безумовно, будуть мотивовані, але я не думав, що вони продовжуватимуть робити це аж три місяці,
причому організовано, а не по-партизанськи. Найбільшою несподіванкою стали численні поразки російських збройних сил.
Багато з того, що, як вони запевняли, вони могли зробити і зробили б, чого навчилися і що нібито удосконалили, на ділі виявилося нісенітницею.
Координація "повітря-земля" та використання повітряних сил - найяскравіші приклади того, що не вдалося з російського боку.
За три місяці бойових дій в Україні Путіну довелося повністю переглянути завдання своєї воєнної операції -
у цьому впевнені більшість західних аналітиків.
Російське вторгнення на початку мало амбітну мету - повне поневолення України та заміну уряду Зеленського на дружнє Москві керівництво.
Ці плани провалилися давно та дуже швидко.
У перші дні російським військам не вдалося не те що зайняти Київ, а навіть оточити його.
Натомість колони з бронетехнікою загрузли на околицях - через запеклий опір українців, а також серйозні проблеми з плануванням та логістикою.
Наприкінці березня російське керівництво відвело війська з регіону та сконцентрувалося на Донбасі.
Російським військовим вдалося захопити значні території поряд із окупованим 2014 року Кримським півостровом.
Але незабаром наступ застопорився і там.
При цьому, за даними британської розвідки, втрати російських військ в Україні за ці три місяці
можна порівняти з втратами СРСР за дев'ять років війни в Афганістані.
Одна з найбільших і знакових втрат російських військових - знищений ракетним ударом крейсер "Москва",
який затонув у середині квітня.
У російської армії проблеми з набором військовослужбовців.
У той час як Україна повністю мобілізована і її підтримує найпотужніший військовий альянс у світі.
Це щодо фізичної складової. З погляду планування у російської армії повний хаос.
Із самого початку не було централізованого підходу, головної лінії нападу, до того ж у ній домінують застарілі командні структури та методи ведення війни.
Україна, особливо за останні вісім років, навчилася ефективному командуванню та управлінню,
вони надають більше командних повноважень та можливостей прийняття рішень нижнім рівням.
Але є ще одна важлива причина провалів російської армії - слабкий моральний дух солдатів, зазначають експерти.
Україна захищає свою батьківщину від жорстокого та лютого ворога, тоді як російські солдати, схоже, не дуже розуміють, що вони там роблять.
На світовій арені за три місяці війни Росія опинилася майже у повній політичній ізоляції.
Міжнародні зустрічі та заходи - від Давоського форуму до "Євробачення" - тепер відбуваються без її участі.
Якщо не брати до уваги Індію та Китай, які продовжують певною мірою підтримувати Росію, країна в ізоляції.
Бізнес-модель національної економіки - експорт газу та нафти - зазнала краху.
Навіть якщо деякі країни все ще купують російські газ і нафту, через п'ять років ця економіка має генерувати свій прибуток зовсім іншим способом.
У воєнному відношенні Росія довела свою нездатність окупувати, завоювати і підкорити навіть невелику сусідню державу.
Тому її сприймають серйозно як велику державу лише тому, що вона має ядерну зброю.
Замість того, щоб стримати розширення НАТО, Путін лише підштовхнув Фінляндію та Швецію до вступу в Альянс.
Від початку повномасштабного вторгнення в Україну США та Євросоюз уже запровадили п'ять пакетів санкцій проти Росії.
На підході - шостий. У ньому - болюча для Кремля відмова від імпорту російської нафти.
Ці заходи боляче б'ють по російській економіці.
Економіка вже сильно постраждала, але багато санкцій матимуть ефект лише у середньостроковій перспективі.
Тобто, як сказала якийсь час тому голова російського Центрального банку Набіулліна, ми на самому початку дії західних санкцій.
Це значно відкине Росію назад. У реальному секторі економіки, у фінансовому секторі, у технологічному секторі -
Росії доведеться платити високу ціну як економічне покарання.
Від початку війни з Росії пішли багато західних фірм - з тисячами робочих місць.
Десятки тисяч молодих та освічених фахівців, особливо в ІТ-сфері, також залишили країну.
Оцінити масштаби реальної підтримки влади, а також протестних та антивоєнних настроїв у країні складно - через репресії, що посилилися.
Будь-кого, хто критикує дії влади, а це доходить до такого абсурду, що людей з книгою Оруелла "1984" у руках, заарештовують як екстремістів.
Це просто показує, наскільки нервово та наскільки репресивно діють державні органи.
Вони, очевидно, досягли успіху, за допомогою придушення альтернативних думок, закриття значної частини опозиційних газет та веб-сайтів,
у тому, щоб змусити велику частину населення згуртуватися навколо президента та захисту від того, що розглядається як зовнішня загроза.
Тепер залишається лише спостерігати, як довго це триватиме.
Водночас деякі коментатори пишуть про невдоволення, що наростає серед російських еліт на тлі тривалої війни в Україні.
Але чи призведе це до зміни влади в Росії найближчим часом? Західні експерти сумніваються.
Так само, як і в тому, чи вдасться армії РФ утримати захоплені в Україні території,
зважаючи на бойовий дух та прагнення перемоги українських збройних сил.